um all right so that's how people can go
get and I got the cheesecake too so I
turn lemons in the lemonade let me speak
about that too because I I always but I
gotta throw it in I was trying to go the
whole interview without talking now but
you gotta feel tired of it yeah I am
tired of it but I'm not never tired yeah
so listen you have your own cheesecake
and what year was making the band 2002
Jesus so in 2002 Making the Band was uh
one of the best reality shows ever the
most iconic episode is when you guys had
to walk to Juniors yes for cheese for
cheesecake yeah very humbling experience
yeah lesson being learning everything
it's not about what you want to do it's
about what needs to be done to get the
job done and you have your own
cheesecake I have my own cheesecake is
it good yes it is how can they get it
follow me on Instagram
that's cheesecake at
n-e-s-s-c-h-e-e-s-e-c-a-k-e is that
something people have to be in Philly to
purchase uh you could purchase it
offline we trying to get the deal with
it because
oh you you got to get the ghost kitchen
and we got the we got the boxes with the
with the with the like the refrigeration
built in with it oh listen all you got
to do is get a ghost kitchen situation
ghost kitchen got to put me up okay have
you ever opened up Postmates and seen
that like DJ Khaled has a restaurant or
like tiger or Wiz Khalifa have like
their own restaurants like in every city
you go to okay what it is is you you'll
you'll hire a ghost kitchen so let's say
you're in LA or you're in New York or
wherever you think you got a big
following right
you find a commercial kitchen that does
Postmates or GrubHub [__] and then you
have you have a restaurant virtually
online in all those cities
and this kitchen handles the Fulfillment
they're pretty much licensing your
likeliness to sell your cheesecake but
they cook it they have the real estate
the receipt you give them they just they
just essentially give you a cut to use
your likeliness oh wow put me on so now
you like like if you open like Postmates
right now you'll see like DJ Khaled has
a restaurant Postmates I got you got you
so he doesn't have a restaurant but he
just they just sell his product they're
giving they using his likeness to sell
100 gotcha yeah it's kind of like
then yes as a lot of people are doing
the ghost kitchen waves and just to
clean it up the album is everywhere
digitally on all everywhere it's on
Spotify it's on Apple music Spotify
Apple music and it might be at a bodega
in Philly somewhere
there it is all right man we'll look
yo new YouTube video with the freestyle
so check it out appreciate you pulling
up brother when's the next battle
award rbear ARP that's versus a ward
stay tuned what is it I don't know I was
supposed to be on the May 10th card ARP
holla at me hmm do you battle people who
are your friends ever always I bet on my
[__] grandmother if the check is
right I like it there it is so I want no
smoke man eating this appreciate you
brother